look it's not gonna be viewing pleasure
for me it's a painful experience so I'm
really doing a nightmare prosecutor
Marcia Clark opened up to et about
experiencing the OJ Simpson trial again
with the Tuesday night premiere of fx's
miniseries
the People vs OJ Simpson it's killing me
all over again watching it happen again
on television is enormous ly painful
what have you got got two victims in
Brentwood killed she praised actress
Sarah Paulsen who portrays her I have to
say when I heard Sarah Paulsen was gonna
play me like what an honor I think she's
a genius and she's an amazing actor
she's an amazing actress she surpassed
anything I could have ever imagined
she's amazing it was the first thing
that you said her first thing I said to
her sorry about that hair Clark also
says she stands with the brown and
Goldman families who have voiced their
anger over the crime drama I'm with him
I agree let's I mean that doesn't I
think actually the series makes an
effort to acknowledge them and and the
ways in which they were forgotten an
important series that's beautifully done
very compelling and I can't thank Ryan
Murphy enough for what he's done here in
terms of raising these issues in a very
serious and compelling and very
substantive way but at the end of the
day two people lost their lives and in a
brutal murder so we we have to remember
that you can't forget them again
remember running a cult